The Mississippi state
Senate is considering
a controversial bill
that critics call the 21st century
Jim Crow.
The area
near the Capitol government buildings
right now in Jackson.
That area has its own district
patrolled by Capitol Police officers.
Republican lawmakers
in the state House
have passed a bill
that would expand that
specially designated district
to encompass
about a third of Jackson's population,
including the densest
populated white neighborhoods
and also some of the city's
most affluent.
This would also set up
a separate court system
for that district.
Jackson as a whole is 83% black.
Critics of this move
say it's
basically the white minority of the city
taking control
from the black leaders
of a majority black city.
It's a move
the city's mayor has called right racist
and likened to apartheid
CNN's Omar
Jimenez is live for us
in Jackson, Mississippi,
at the state capitol, no more.
The state Senate has made a few key
changes to the House bill.
How are residents
and city leaders reacting
to those changes?
Yeah, we
just got out of the
hearing with some of those residents
and city leaders.
And really what they said
they were voicing concerns
about how to address
public safety
here in Jackson,
where violence has spiked
in recent years.
But more specifically,
they were voicing
concerns about this bill.
Now, some of the key changes
from when it was first introduced
on the House side
to where it is now on the Senate side
is rather than having a single district
with these state
appointed judges
and an expanded jurisdiction
of this Capitol Police force.
That jurisdiction now expands citywide.
You still, though, have the issue
of having judges
appointed by state leaders,
which in this case are majority white
instead of elected judges in a city
that is more than 80% black.
So therein lies one of the major issues.
And that jurisdiction of the Capitol
Police
force would expand citywide
meant to strike an agreement
with the Jackson
police force on how to police,
in theory, together.
So I want you to take a listen
to the district attorney
over the area of Jackson,
along with the mother
of a man
who was killed
by a Capitol police officer
and why she believes this
expansion is not a good idea.
It's laughable to talk about
new bills doing new things.
We have now addressed the old problems.
The problem is not the police.
The problem is the system
that we're not funding
to actually get the system working,
because I know there are bills
that is legislate.
This legislature has introduced
that will expand Capitol Police Authority
possibly to the entire city of Jackson.
And that terrifies me.
It also angers me
and there is a lot of anger around this.
You look no further than T-shirts.
We've seen
that it's
Jackson versus
everybody,
which is how many residents feel
now, proponents of this bill,
including its Republican sponsors,
say that this is really needed
to help
keep Jackson safer
and to increase and bolster
resources towards judges
in these cases, or a judiciary
that hasn't seen as much investment
to keep up with the pace
of what they've had to deal with.
But obviously,
opponents of this
say there are better ways
to address those concerns than this.
All right.
Omar Herman is in Jackson, Mississippi.
Thanks so much.
Let's bring in the mayor,
Chokwe Antar Lumumba.
Mayor Lumumba,
thanks so much for joining us.
So the state Senate version of the bill
would remove the creation
of this new unelected court system
for parts of Jackson
where a majority of the city's
white population lives,
which would you likened to apartheid.
But the state Senate version
does still expand state control over
other parts of Jackson.
Are you satisfied with the changes
made to the bill by the state Senate?
When I think
about this
bill in both of its forms,
I think about the legal
principle of race.
It's a lot quicker,
which simply means that it is flawed
in its very nature.
And so even with the changes,
it is still an attack
on black leadership.
It still is a Trojan horse
cloaked in the notion of public safety,
where it is not evidence based,
where it looks to not only fail
to support
the needs of the city
that have been enumerated for many years.
We have asked the state legislature
for support
in terms of ballistic technology
to close cases.
We have asked the state
for support of our 21st century
real time crime center.
That helps officers
and when a crime is actively in progress.
We have asked for support
of violence, interruption programing
and credible messenger programing
all which have been denied
and have have met
a deliberate indifference
or willful disregard of Jackson's needs
in order to have evidence
based solutions,
you would need to know
that the overwhelming
majority of our violent crimes
in Jackson are interpersonal.
And so that is a very difficult matter
to police And so we're trying to enter,
intercede or or stop this cycle
where people are taking
permanent solutions
to temporary problems.
And bring other resources
and other forms of intervention to
to the table in order for it
to help our residents.
One of the bill's chief sponsors,
State Representative Trey Lamar.
He denies any racial motivation
behind the legislation.
He says the bill is an effort
to address
that crime in Jackson is soaring
and there's a backlog in the courts.
How do you respond?
Well, first and foremost,
we just listen to the testimony
of Cliff Johnson
today of the MacArthur Justice Foundation
that did a actual true
data comparison of the backlogs of
Hines County
in comparison to other counties
in the state of Mississippi to scale.
What you find is that there isn't
a significant backlog
in comparison to other places.
Cliff Johnson
also when asked, I'm not Cliff Johnson.
Trey Lamar, when asked at the dais
defending his bill
why he felt that
judges needed to be appointed rather than
elected, he said, Well,
we simply want the best of the best.
That feeds
into the notion of inferiority.
That feeds into the notion
that this largely majority
black city
is not smart enough
or equipped enough to know
who best represents them.
And there is no evidence based rationale
for for the creation of this district,
whichever version.
First of all,
if you take the first version
we would need to ask from Trey Lamar
while his version of the bill selected
the most densely
populated white portion of the city.
Jackson is 80 85% black,
but that portion is about 86% encompasses
86% of the white population of Jackson.
Was that by mere happenstance?
There are no state facilities
within that district.
And so, you know,
he is using the Trojan horse
that has been used historically
on a number of occasions.
In order to disenfranchize
and in order to abuse
largely black populations.
What would you say to a constituent
who says, Mr.
Mayor, I hear you and I agree.
I don't I don't trust the motivation
of these individuals.
But Jackson recorded
the highest murder rate in the country
for a city of over
100,000 people in 20, 21.
Crime is a huge problem in Jackson.
I'd rather have something than nothing.
And they're not going to fund
what you're asking for.
This at least would
provide some relief for the police
that exist in the area
that will not be included in this.
Yeah,
but what I would say
is that their concern is the my concern.
And that is why
we continue to look for new solutions.
That is why
we not only recruit more officers,
but talk about and build
the institutions
that I've told you about,
such as our real time
command center,
which we've done
through our own resources.
We've joined in with Wells
Fargo Bank and National League of Cities
to create an office
of violence prevention
and trauma recovery
so that for every new officer out
west, we're bringing on new officers,
we're bringing on
additional interventions,
bringing in social workers
and mental health experts
to help curtail
some of the challenges
that we see in our community.
Our sharpest rise
in violence has been among
our youngest demographic.
And so instead of doing a curfew
where there isn't detention centers
to hold people,
nor does it truly get to the root
cause of why
young people may find themselves
in vulnerable places at vulnerable times.
How do we have people who are specialized
in the area
of working with that population
so that we teach, train
and support young people
that they don't
take permanent solutions
to their temporary problems?
We can talk about it continue,
not only in addition to the things
that I mentioned,
other supports
that help our police department,
but what we don't want to do
in a moment of
crisis is reach for a solution
which is worse
than where we find ourselves.
All right.
Jackson Mayor Chokwe Antar Lumumba,
thank you so much.
For your time today, sir.
We appreciate it.
Thank you.